The first thing that's important to remember is that the first coordinate we
have in any ordered pair is the horizontal position of the point, and the second
coordinate is the vertical position. So, let's start with the first point as an
example. We have an x coordinate of 1. So we move from the origin over to the
right in a positive direction 1, and a y-coordinate of 2, so we move up two,
that's point b. For the second one, we have negative 2 as our x value so
starting at the origin, we count to the left in the negative direction 1, 2. And
then, the y value is 1 so we count up one. So, that's point d. And we can do the
same process for every other point on here. So here, so here are the final
answers, luckily none of my letters are the same in any of the boxes cause that
would indicate that we had made a mistake. Every pair has a unique position on
the coordinate plane. And in the same way, every position on the coordinate
plane has a unique ordered pair